SPEAKER: Let's take a quick look
at how to use to Google Cloud
SQL proxy.
Go to cloud.google.com, and
open up your Cloud console.
Go to the SQL section.
Here you can see your
Cloud SQL instances.
If you don't have a Cloud SQL
instance, you can create one.
Click your instance to be taken
to the Instance Overview page.
Now, go to the
Access Control tab,
and then go to the Users tab.
Specify a new root password.
Go to the following
page to follow along
with the rest of the tutorial.
Scroll down and
click Enable the API.
Choose your project,
and click Continue.
The API should now be enabled.
Follow the installation
instructions
for your operating system.
Now run gcloud auth
application-default login.
Go back to the
SQL overview page,
and copy the instance
connection name.
Run the Cloud SQL proxy,
and pass in your instance
connection name.
At the end of the string, you
also want to type in =tcp:3306.
You now have a direct
connection to Cloud SQL
through the local proxy.